[Music]
here we talk about the news so we can't
avoid this topic we have to talk about
monkey pox dude it's everywhere
i had a [ __ ] nightmare last night i
had monkeys and [ __ ] it was all over my
skin and i was popping it like a [ __ ]
pimple and it was a little scary huh oh
god damn dude there's no death still
right now
oh it looks disgusting it looks like
those ads that you see where like you
see a patch of skin and you see like a
bunch of pores and you see a bunch of
black things in it or like and they're
like what the [ __ ] is that and then you
click on it and then it's like whoa this
could really happen to you when you
click on it and like this is a [ __ ]
scam ad
god damn it oh my monkey box is a scam
ad no but it looks like that that's how
intense it looks yeah it looks nuts yeah
it looks like a fake disease it looks
like a fake disease if you're trying to
tell you somebody photoshopped the lotus
[ __ ] inside with the seeds and [ __ ]
on somebody exactly oh like a
tripophobia stuff yeah yeah trapophobia
vibes all the way but how many cases is
in cali now eight
how many cisco is on uh emergency
california is wait did you say cali
mm-hmm that is so weird what i i don't
know like
californians don't say calories no we
only say the [ __ ] golden state that's
really hawaiian to say
california like is he not from from
california
he just said i hear cali all right so
far oh that's just so weird i hear a lot
of east coasters say i'm going to cali
yeah i hear that i hear people from not
in california usa cali where are you
from from california where are you from
in california in los angeles everyone
says it's not even real coffee
everyone is in l.a why didn't you say
los angeles i don't know i got nervous
i was like who says
you're not really julia are you i know
that let me guess you used to work at
just kidding yes
just kidding yeah something's weird here
just because these guys are from nev
they know what's up
you know we don't say
nevadian right
it's like nevadian or something oh
you're supposed to say it like with a a
it's wrong what i'm a less vegan yeah i
said i'm a vegan that's what i said
philosophy you're las vegas yeah that's
good that's good so
out of the entire united states so far
total confirmed monkey pox cases are six
thousand six hundred and seventeen in
the u.s in the us oh thank god
california is 826 holy [ __ ] out of all
of the united states uh new york
has 1600 and california is the second
highest with 800. you know you know what
i've been reading uh and this is no
jokes right it's been in every single
publication
they always add that it's
highly contagious with men who have sex
with men what i haven't heard that
really i don't know how true that is
though
i just feel like that's just propaganda
against them nah bro gay dudes be
[ __ ] all the time i mean yeah sure
they'll be [ __ ] all the time but i
don't think they're the reason for
monkey problems
it's high in the it's it's higher
in probability with men that have sex
with men
they bust it down dog yeah we hung out
with some gay dudes in palm springs
[ __ ] the whole time and they were
telling us about it like i [ __ ] that
dude just now and we were like kicking
with them at the pool and they were just
telling us that's the most fun i was
thinking right the most dude have you
guys seen the guy
he was like he was recording and this he
has monkey pox on his face oh what the
[ __ ] so he was like yeah it's this is
real like i'm a real life whatever
person and then he goes i got it from
every boyfriend and then he goes my
boyfriend got it from his other partner
oh yeah
there's another guy in the video taking
care of them and i guess they all have
monkey balls but he recovered so which
is why he can be in the video to record
them so like that was the first time
he's seen monkey boxing video that's
crazy
a bunch of my clients that work in like
hospitals they're all telling me how
they see it they they've they have
patients that they have been working
with that have monkey pods when they
come in do they gotta wear like suits or
are they scared yeah oh i know they have
to swab it we just got over one pandemic
why the [ __ ] you know and then this was
this one's lockdown worthy i think it
was scarier this one's scarier than
[ __ ] kobe even though it has a no
like fatality right it's so scary right
i know it looks scary it's cosmetically
bad alls i know is that so with covet
right it originated
from the wet markets in china
these poor people in china eating bats
and pieces of [ __ ]
giving us all covered and now
i know for a fact
that gay people
are giving us monkey pox
i know it for a fact
by the way do i think any of this came
from labs
no
came from government labs no way no
scenario
is there any pictures of uh i would
never blame these communities someone
with monkey pox from like like a new
photo from here in this stage i saw
asian dude that they just posted on um
because i keep seeing the old stuff for
they've been using forever that same
picture no no there's there's people
like in the states with it let's see
that's the video that i saw
yeah i want to see what it looks like
now look at this uh i think they just
got the first case in um pasadena yeah
pasadena dude i think i sent that to you
but no it's everywhere doug i feel like
everyone in california i i had like four
different clients this is monkey pots on
the face
a little bit oh whoa that is crazy
there's a little bit of jam and they say
it's like painful and you get fevers it
looks like the guy just ate chocolate
cake
it's uh they say it's it comes it
happens uh skin skin to skin contact
yeah extend it extend it extend it so
[ __ ] hence the sex
yeah right
yeah so that's really the correlative
when they some who is it that said that
about the gay guys
being the i saw it on real news no
[ __ ] oh yeah
i saw it on [ __ ] msn scene beat cmbc
that's right i saw it on [ __ ] like um
ad supported so the reason for that is
because gay guys tend to just be more
physically no well
all i'm reading is like they'll tell you
the like it's been like it's it's
happening here whatever whatever and
then how it's contacted right like
touching [ __ ] whatever kissing and it
says it's
right now there's uh there's a lot of uh
high cases with men ha that have sex
with men that's the pattern all i know
is that every time anything happens they
use the same playbook they blame poor
people and gays and well yeah no really
it's aids they're blaming all the
[ __ ] gay same [ __ ]
it's incredible it's like actually wild
how much they use the same [ __ ]
playbook and then oh eventually we find
out oh wait sorry there was a lab in
china called the
lab coronavirus lab and they're
researching this yeah yeah maybe it
leaked from there sorry and somehow
fauci has invested into it but they
blame the poor people in wet markets
first of course
i called that [ __ ] out at the time i'm
like yeah i'm sure it was a bunch of
poor people
just like to eat bats and pangolins
anymore just like let's live just like
with fannie mae freddie mac right who'd
they blame the poor people they got
these irresponsible lows all these
[ __ ] stupid poor people i [ __ ]
hate all these poor people getting those
loans and guess what and what happened
with coven they they inflate the money
supply big time right they blame you for
getting a [ __ ] check for 1300
out of a year of not working and they
blame you for the for the inflation
problem
it's not their fault it's not who they
gave the money to since you guys [ __ ]
did this whole inflation [ __ ] i'm gonna
give you more money to cover your dumb
asses give your dumb [ __ ] stupid
asses 250 for gas print more money and
cause more inflation to save your asses
so the white house is now scrambling to
play catch up on the monkey pox response
obviously administration officials have
acknowledged they need to ramp up their
efforts as the number of cases has grown
faster than initially expected did we
not learn anything from covet dude who
will they scapegoat next i'm excited
about it they already did it it would be
interesting it is an action but who's
next where did it come from
i don't know man i think we're gonna go
into another lockdown i [ __ ] hope not
dude i hope it's dolly i don't think
they could do it like the people will
revolt i don't think it's even a revolt
thing i just think yeah i think it's i
don't think they can afford it yeah i
think i think it's that cuz what happens
next because they're gonna inflate the
money supply more yeah dude we're [ __ ]
if that happens we're already in a bad
spot anyway we're not enough we're not
in a recession though no it's not a
recession
oh no way and inflation's actually good
for you already here's the funny thing
they've never done this before it's
really good for your
five new approach the administration is
working to drastically increase the
number of people vaccinated against
monkeybox
and improve access to an experimental
treatment for those infected right in
addition to naming a monkeypox
coordinator to manage the response from
the white house across agencies and with
state and local governments
so did monkey cox was the name because
someone [ __ ] a monkey and [ __ ] and
then like now they got the monkey pox
and now it's like or did a monkey just
sneeze on a human being because i hope
it's it's that no it's like supposed to
be like some sort of like
i don't know if it's like a virus or
just like an illness that's like from
one breed to another breed so like the
jump
like swine flu i actually read that
that's not true i read that there's a
guy who's like they're like how'd you
get what happened last night he's like
i think i [ __ ] the bunker
i was really drunk man oh you're so
bugged out of the club you wake up and
then you look at who you're next to oh
[ __ ] like you know when you're like in a
bar and you like look at a cage and you
see somebody and you think it's a golden
answer but it was actually a monkey the
next day
it was yourself it was a zoo
and it's a chimpanzee with a lipstick
next to you and it was a corporate event
and you realize that your company leased
out part of a zoo
it was universal studios animal actors
yeah
that's great that's what happened it was
so hot though i said in total the us has
reported almost 6 000 cases since the
beginning of may the total worldwide
exceeds 20 000. and even says here with
the virus currently spreading almost
entirely among men who have sex with men
almost entirely
look see
again this is nbc news stuff to you by
the way why don't they just tell us like
why the administration strategy has
largely largely been focused on
vaccinating the most high-risk
individuals who include men who have had
multiple male partners in a two-week
period that's the only one that doesn't
get the vaccine exposure
they said the same [ __ ] when [ __ ]
aids and hiv was going down they're
blaming the gay community
but before that johnson
but before that yeah and then they were
also but they were also saying they as
in the [ __ ] media and all these weird
people were saying that humans [ __ ] the
monkey and then that's how it's happened
oh yeah
that's that's how they said aids
happened now we have monkey box it's
good
it's good it's wild so that's what
they're that's that's the silent text
behind saying that men who have sex with
men get it more is that they're pretty
forward with that they even say um
more recently administration officials
have urged other men who have uh who
have sex with men to cut down on
high-risk behavior like having multiple
partners until the outbreak is under
control they're attempting to get the
word uh that word out to gay transgender
and bisexual communities through dating
apps at events and engagement with
communities so it's so can be super
contagious then right uh the federal
government has said it plans to ship
more than 700 000 vaccine doses to
states on top of the 300 000 already
allocated but officials haven't detailed
plans for any additional doses
once the data showed that this outbreak
was different than past ones and
transmitting rapidly we scaled up our
comprehensive response rapidly
accelerating timelines to make over one
million doses of vaccines available
this is scary man i don't want any more
[ __ ] do you think he's gonna be the
first to get it
here
getting multiple partners
on the count of three point at somebody
okay
one
two
three
[Laughter]
i didn't point anybody
anthony you didn't you don't have a vote
i'm a host i think you'll get a good
my wife was telling me the same thing
she was like hey you better be careful
when you teach that's what i was
thinking because taika does jiu jitsu
so i was like oh there's probably gonna
be kids and [ __ ] i don't know because
it's extended contact you i wonder if
it's like if it's like chicken pox and
it's just gonna be a part of you just
need it
you just need to need it you just get it
get out of your system
fatalities and it could be a lot like
chicken pox i heard it's really painful
though that's what i heard i mean
chicken pox is like getting shingles
then because shingles are really painful
shingles are terrible bro i'm just
excited to see what comes next and who
they blame next
i'm excited to see that too what
underserved community will be hit next
yeah yo what if it actually says uh men
who have sex with men but it says slash
jiu-jitsu fighters
they'll be crazy wrestlers
or they're like this next one oh it's
all hungry people
of people that are hungry hungry people
who avoid their taxes i swear to god
these [ __ ] hungry people
you